-Our next guest is
a best-selling author,
entrepreneur,
and the woman you wish
would host all your parties.
You can now shop her lifestyle
on martha.com.
Please welcome back to the show
one of our favorites,
Martha Stewart, everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back. How are you?
-I've missed you.
-I missed you, too.
Do you have a nicer pool
than Chelsea Handler?
Yeah, I thought so.
[ Laughter ]
-And my new pool is really nice.
-Oh, you already have
a new pool as well.
Look at you.
-[ Posh voice ] It's very fancy.
-[ Laughs ]
Hey, I read something about you
that I found fascinating
that I wanted to ask you about.
You said one of
your biggest regrets was
that you did not host "SNL."
So this was something you were
asked to do and you said no to?
-Yeah. Emerging from jail...
-Yes.
-"Yail, emerging from "Yail."
-Yes. You're a "Yail" graduate.
-Graduate.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I was asked to host the show,
and I was so excited
and my parole officer
would not let me have the time.
-Really?
-I hate that guy.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I hate him.
It was the right time,
it was the perfect time,
I was in a good mood,
I was thin.
[ Laughter ]
-That's what
a lot of people say.
You do a couple weeks in "Yail,"
you're gonna lose the weight.
[ Laughs ]
-Anyway.
-Yes.
-Onward and upward.
You have a new website,
martha.com.
-I do.
-What can we find there?
-Well, all things that I
designed, things that I curate,
things that I think you should
know about, content, you know,
overflowing content.
-Is there a product
that you think
I in particular really need?
-There's lots of things,
lots of things.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Knowing you for so many years,
I know that there are things
that you would find interesting,
useful,
and you're gardening now
and, you know, you're doing
all those things,
so there's all that stuff.
-I have a robust gardening
career right now.
-Oh, good, good.
What are you growing?
-I don't know what you're
talking about, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I thought
you were a gardener.
-No!
-Oh, who does that?
-Who does my gardening?
-Yeah.
-Well, I don't know.
-People? They come in?
-I don't have -- what do you --
I don't have a garden.
I feel like you're once again
confusing me with you.
-I must be.
-Yeah, you must be.
So you had a -- This made
a quite a bit of news.
You had a tag sale at your home.
Now, first of all, what is --
-You did not come.
-I did not come.
-Guess guess who sent
his emissaries.
-Who sent emissaries?
-Jimmy Fallon.
-Jimmy Fallon?
-He sent his decorator.
-He sent his decorator?
-Yep, and she bought five
beautiful spool beds.
-Spool beds?
-Yeah, beautiful beds.
They're doing, like, a camp room
for the kids.
-I told you years ago, when
the spool beds come available --
-I know, and you --
-Call me directly.
-And you did not show up.
-I did not show up.
-Actually, there were so many
people, it was a huge success,
and I'm never gonna
have another one.
-So tell me, what is --
For those for those
who are maybe on the outside
looking in,
what's the difference between,
say, a tag sale and a yard sale?
-Not much.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-Not much. It's fancier.
-A fancy way to say --
-Well, we had
a very fancy yard sale.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Tag sale, garage sale,
estate sale -- it was sort of a
combination of all those things.
-Gotcha.
How many items did you sell?
-Many thousands.
-Wow!
-Yeah, many thousands.
-Many thousands.
-And we had a few thousand
people come.
They had to buy tickets.
It was all for philanthropy.
-That's lovely.
-Yeah, so we raised
a lot of money for my for
my hospital at Mount Sinai.
-And when you look through your
items before you put them
out for sale, what was
the strangest thing you found?
-Oh, well, I had so many
buildings full of stuff
that I really wanted to
get rid of,
but one thing that almost got
sold and then the person
who had picked it up,
gave it back to me
was my daughter Alexis's health
record from when she was born.
Those little books that you fill
out -- roseola, measles shots,
all those nice, little things
that you really would like
to remember.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ] Roseola.
-Did you accidentally
put it for sale?
-Somebody put it for sale.
There were other people
going through my stuff.
-Gotcha. Okay, good.
So this wasn't that somebody --
So the person returned it
as a favor.
-Yeah. They did.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-They were gonna take it,
but they gave it back.
-That's very sweet.
-But somebody took
my gardening cart, and I didn't
want to sell that one,
and that got sold,
and I couldn't take it back.
-But you will hunt them down
and find them?
-Definitely.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-When I need the cart for
a TV show or something.
-Now, this is very exciting.
-But it's on TV, we --
-Yeah, you filmed the tag sale.
So it's gonna be
a special this week.
Was everybody well-behaved?
Because sometimes --
-No!
-Was this like one of those
Black Friday things
but in a beautiful lawn?
-No, no, there were some people
who -- There was a big --
Well, you'll see it on the show.
-Okay.
-You should watch the show.
-Were there limits for how much
people could buy?
-No.
-Okay. Yeah.
-But there was a limit to the
stuff and the people who came
on the second day, because they
hadn't gotten their money in
soon enough for the first day.
-Yeah.
-Some of them were a little
pissed off about
not having enough stuff for sale
on the second day.
But, you know, that's the nature
of a tag sale.
-Yeah.
-You know, you sell out.
You hope you sell out.
-Yeah.
Get with the program, everybody.
-Right.
-I have to ask you about this.
I'm very excited about
this news.
You're gonna make a maze.
-An amazing maze.
-So this is like
a hedgerow maze?
-Yes.
-Okay.
-Each row is of a different type
of tree or shrub.
-Okay.
-It's my idea for a maze.
I've been thinking about a maze
for a long time,
and I have a 3-acre paddock
that I'm taking away
from my horses to do this maze.
-Have you broken it
to the horses yet?
-Well, I took -- I planted like
four big rows so far,
and I took my horse on a ride
through the maze.
We got lost already,
which is great.
And it's like dressage.
You know, you go in there
and you have to make these sharp
turns, and he actually liked it
because it makes them think.
-Yeah.
-And so I can't wait to get
the whole thing done.
But the largest maze
in the world is
the Dole pineapple maze
in Hawaii.
-I think we all know that.
-Did you?
[ Laughter ]
2.2 acres.
-2.2 acres.
-And this paddock is 3 acres,
so...
-You're gonna set
a Guinness world record?
-Yep, that's the idea.
-That's really exciting.
-Yep, but I have to find enough
plant material.
It's hard to find
that many trees.
I've already planted
like 600 trees in there.
-Excuse my ignorance,
but you're planting --
I'm assuming the trees
you're planting
are already grown trees?
-Well, some of them are
3 feet tall,
and they'll get denser.
And the boxwoods were only about
this tall.
But I'm doing yews and boxwood
and proteas and beech trees
and hemlocks -- not hemlocks --
and hornbeams.
So I'm doing a lot of different
plant material.
It's colorful, too.
-That's really exciting.
-Yes.
-You should do your next
tag sale in the maze.
[ Laughter ]
And then instead of people
buying tickets to get in,
you sell them tickets
to get out.
-But I think what's gonna happen
is, I think,
once people start to think about
mazes again --
this was a medieval
kind of enjoyment.
Mazes and all the castles
had mazes.
If you look up history of mazes,
it's really kind of interesting,
but -- and right now,
all throughout the world,
there are some very interesting
mazes available for visits.
But I don't know of
a really modern one.
So this is going to be
a fun thing.
[ Laughter ]
You could grow one, too.
-I am not gonna make a maze.
[ Laughter ]
-You might.
-I might, you're right.
You know what?
There's a lot of things
I said I'd never do.
-You might want to lose the kids
sometime.
-Yeah, that's true.
[ Laughter ]
-People are gonna
get lost in it.
-I'm gonna send them over to
your house and be like,
"You're going over to Aunt
Martha's, go in the maze!
See you on Monday!"
-They are totally welcome.
-Martha Stewart, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You can check out her beautiful
website now at martha.com.
We'll be right back
with Allegra Hyde.